38. daddy look at his chest daddy looked
at himself in the mirror and i'm not bad
naked i'm not bad naked no i still i got
no fat on me daddy's no oh chin
for you so as i sing christian's gonna
go and like
we're doing karaoke
stuff
asian singing
i love this it's a little bit like hey
you're [ __ ] my song i love you oh you
want that fact
you know better than me yeah you because
you're the audio guy i'll do this right
we follow your lead all right here we go
yep
happy birthday
to you
happy birthday
to
you
happy
birthday to you
brian
aka the rink springs yes
they don't make them like that no more
come on brian you got it come on man you
got you got lungs oh yeah i love the old
crap
you're just trying to give people
coverage
[Music]
that's how you do it
i ain't eating nothing since uh last
night i do that fasting thing now and so
so that cupcake what's your birthday
yeah
did do you do anything last night for
the b day i didn't i i i just did some
work yeah what is he going to do what is
he doing i've been doing work
and uh but that's it no i i feel better
when i'm working when i'm writing you're
doing stanton
i was doing some other stuff i got some
stuff going on okay coming up
so you did nothing last night for your
birthday i uh i did nothing yeah you
just did nothing i got you know what it
is
when you bring when you bring an infant
home uh-huh you bring it oh my gosh
you're invisible in that house dude he's
understood yeah that
well that baby doesn't need you and my
mother my my girl's mom is there and my
girl and they've got baby and
and
they basically forgot about my birthday
and that's okay because it doesn't
matter
well they don't know what day it is
they're probably going no sleep correct
correct because i'm not waking up and
feeding the kids yeah i just hear
you sleep in the same room yeah but i'm
like all right
i'm not i'm not the guy who's like let
me let me uh i just i'm sorry
yeah i gotta i gotta sleep it's your
birthday it's my birthday you know the
gift they gave you sleep that's exactly
they gave me sleep and that's what you
need and i'm not that sentimental when
it comes to a birthday it's not a baby
baby
baby you should be or a bad person but
first birthday i get baby let's be a
little more interested because i thought
he was going to save birth
twice now so let's kind of no no i've
got better now three times here's the
thing i love my i'm enjoying the [ __ ]
out of my kids now my ten-year-old my
thirteen-year-old enjoying the [ __ ] at
him when you got a two-week-old
i don't have a lot in common with the
kid and frankly i got in a little
trouble i'ma say it out loud my girl
goes well what are we going to do and i
go no let's just go do this and she goes
but the baby and i go
i'm bored right now he's the child's
bored me i've been with the kid for an
hour you're bored and i'm allowed to say
it's a little boring isn't that boring
well
a baby sleeps
a terrible day the baby at that age is a
previous so he's sleeping all the time
he needs a lot of [ __ ] like yeah you got
to be honest so he's changing diet oh
yeah oh yeah then that's not boring
that's like that's like you're on it
it's just not his thing you feed him
it's just not his thing no i do don't
make me out to be the bad guy i don't
think i am here i know you yeah you're
you're delivering everything right now
like after an hour man i was [ __ ]
bored
i love my kids no but yeah i love my
kids when they're 10 and 12 you do yeah
i mean to stare at a sleeping baby there
is a limit
but what you want to do
well
you take care of it you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah i want to go i want to
go for a run
that's not fair
or just go for
let me watch a show hang out in the
restaurant yeah
i was home i'm home it's just that the
baby you know we can watch a show yeah
and that's what i did or she can do it
so you didn't do that she did but i was
there you're in the house i was there in
the house no i guess what i'm trying to
say is a lot of people say my life began
when the child when i saw the baby's
eyes open well it's your third goal
yeah yeah yeah
you know what i mean it's like and
you're doing it in your 50s yeah yeah so
it's like i love the kids mid 50s
i'm mid 50s you you're friends for the
midfield
newborn
mid-50s are you hugh hefner i have one i
have one friend like that would call
each other and i'm like are you doing
manny because i am yeah
i mean
i am you haven't been there oh my god
yeah yeah so you know 55. now you're
going to celebrate your
you celebrate your b day tonight on
stage though yeah celebrate my b day i'm
just around your friends that would be
fun that'll be good bring the baby i'll
bring the baby
to the crowd but apparently the baby's
so young that you're not i know i was
just a joke
you'd get better but get better that was
a joke yeah my girl would do it my girl
like wants to bring her baby oh i
wouldn't allow her that wouldn't allow
the baby in the green room because he
can't do that to a newborn yeah newborn
not so safe that's a lot and you just
got the nicu and everybody's like oh and
they're over the baby
yeah or whooping cough or something [ __ ]
polio and who knows what those scumbags
have like you got to be careful brian
you don't bring into a well i did that
already with my 13 year old i brought
that in my throat she's 13 yeah she can
handle it yeah but there's nobody
censoring themselves
we're exactly 20 years and three days
apart you and i that crazy 20 years in
three days yep i'm the 23rd he's the
26th now now you and i were talking
about the tough mudder um i'm i'm
very i'm doing it because i don't know
how i'm gonna do it with my yeah that's
the thing it's such a such a blind thing
to me i thought i had this problem my
[ __ ] lower calves just my feet are
gonna break down and that's okay i feel
like i feel like i'm going to break down
i may have to stop and rub them out or
something yeah that's fine yeah i mean
hopefully it's gonna be a nightmare i
mean i don't know it might be doing my
hammy's holding
what are we doing but i mean we're doing
it oh yeah there's no turning back
there's no turning on principle
like that's the thing that's keeping me
like but your body's fine you should be
able to power through it like even if
the watch i guess it's just that running
that is like the long distance running
is what's going on yeah not going to be
running sorry that won't
you know what you do you just you get
wear good shoes take some
anti-inflammatories and just plod
through it yeah you have fun yeah we'll
have fun it's like
oprah ran a marathon she did yeah oh i
got this [ __ ] yeah god bless you must be
harder than the marathon but um
wait
26
she ran 226 miles the obstacles are
tough shin is that real life yeah
i believe she did
berta bert does marathons without even
training he did like the boston marathon
because the la marathon doesn't train at
all bert burtle surprised your bird's
stronger than you think burnt healthy
bert held two mugs of beer look out bro
okay first of all
that was in 1994
but still that's incredible
phenomenal shape i had no idea she used
to look like that yeah no she had lost
weight for a period of time and she got
that [ __ ] back i mean you know
four hours and 30 minutes i mean yeah
yeah you were around when you was 17.
you're wrong no i'd like to but really i
have no interest in that yeah no life is
true my adopted father runs him like
[ __ ] nothing he ran the grand canyon
yeah like rim the rim like he does he's
going to run 50 miles for us 50th yes
now christian hit us with uh
apparently tough mudder posted a thing
where you go through uh tear gas yeah so
uh they
i don't they didn't say specifically if
it was going to be in it but let's just
hope that it's not because that's what i
would say why else would they go through
because they said just in 2020 and plus
they had people going through the
through the damn thing so so it's going
to be rough so is it that i wonder if
it's a tear gas or electric i'd rather
be tear gas than electrocuted
tear gas if it's short enough you can
close your eyes and hold your breath and
stand through i agree really yeah the
electrocution was terrible yeah yeah was
it like this can i be honest with you
i'm afraid i'm very afraid of you you
should be yeah yeah they're like when
you're in the water if they set up like
last time water go to that don't be a
cry baby that's what it is in the water
though let's take a little break from
chatting god knows what with chappelle
lacy because guess what dude this
podcast is brought to you by better
health better help we all need it man
you got to take care of your brain you
got to take care of your mind it's one
thing to take care of your body eat
nutritionally but sometimes mental
health is something we overlook well
it's the most important thing it is you
shouldn't overlook check out the big
brain ombre you can talk to a you can
literally be better help will assess
your needs and they match you with your
own licensed professional thing
professional is key here it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help no it's
professional therapy done securely
online you can be start you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it's
worldwide all right it's cheaper than
going to in-person therapy and they got
you covered man start working on
yourself we're talking about your mental
health it's so freaking important uh
there's financial aid available as well
for you guys all right and we got a
special offer for the fine kid listeners
and viewers get temps off your first
month at betterhelp that's
betterhelp.com
fighter two million people have taken
charge of their mental health with
better help so you know
and they all do it with an experienced
professional so take advantage uh better
help they're recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states talk to your
friends talk to real professionals
better help that's better
betterhelphelp.com
fighter i hear athletic queens are good
great yeah they're great yeah
athletic greens brandon you are a very
busy man you need a little boost you
can't don't always have time to take in
phytonutrients bioflavonoids all the
things you get from
my diet i'm on carnivore so i gotta make
up some of those greens some nutrients
so i just take some of that put a little
athletic greens eight ounces of water
place is a multivitamin with real
natural sourced foods it helps with
digestion energy everything else it
tastes fantastic all right it's just
it's super easy talking about 75
vitamins minerals whole food source
ingredients
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend all in one it's delicious all
right very tasty it's fantastic man and
there listen
join the movement right now with
athletes if you run the thick mud or the
tough mudder if you're a mom you a new
dad what are you doing keto what if
you're paleo what if you're vegan what
if you're very friendly all that daddy
we got you covered man to make it easy
athletic greens is gonna give you immune
supporting free one year supply of
vitamin d
five free travel packs with your first
purchase when you visit
athleticgreens.com fighter today again
all you do is visit athleticgreens.com
fighter to take control of your health
and give a g one a try
[Music]
look at everybody just having fun though
okay i guess i'm not
not too worried
it's called cry baby
[Music]
i actually went through twice i had so
much fun in there
well okay all right quick question am i
going to be the only black person at
this event no i like that okay that's
pretty cool
you'll be the second
hey yo guess what
i got to skate with tony hawk
oh damn yeah because jason ellis yeah
he's just a show with him right yeah
went down to his uh rampant stuff and
skated with him
there he is right there oh that's so we
have two different videos right chapel
this one we have two videos right this
one and then ellis dude the one that's
really cool is the one that uh jason
ellis posted
uh it's his instagram is wolf mate yeah
he's got a dope yeah okay and go to
scroll and there's that video right
there and you guys went to
tony hawk's yeah please see everybody
catch him in [ __ ] chuck chucks on a
friday night
who said that jason ellis
and also
it's a local skate contest where he
shreds it up watch this
oh [ __ ]
oh you're getting a birdman lesson
a birdman lesson yeah
then he starts pushing me i'm a big boy
this is a
uh half pipe yeah i don't know
half pipes you're not that good huh no
the other video i'm good but this is
you know just going up and down yeah but
i needed a different board because my
board's a street board or unless you're
good at skateboarding no i'm really good
no eat a dick i i am really good do that
you're more of a street yeah
go to my profile i wouldn't [ __ ] with
that half ramp at all dude that's 13
foot don't go to that one that's that
one's him pushing me again your profile
no go to my profile
this [ __ ] guy don't believe in my
skating uh scroll a little bit
uh
right there yeah
legit yeah hit the next one
oh you don't think so brian no no that's
not good enough morning i've done a lot
but that's i've seen it done a lot what
that's good
i don't know anybody else you can do
that
i do
oh
that's pretty good boom homie is this
guy serious oh oh it's it's brian's
birthday apparently on your birthday
you're a hater yeah i hate her hate it
on your newborn son amon chappelle
skateboard you can't [ __ ] skate yeah
skateboarders do yeah the kick flip yeah
dolly
you know what dude oh you're salty on
your behalf
55 really hit down on your beat
i'll get down on my b day two no no
no no no
i will let you have
the [ __ ] dude i watch alex humbled
free solo
free
solo [ __ ] el cap and i get this watch
this i get this i get
and i go
oh
and he goes i'm just don't think it's
that impressive no i never says i'm
pregnant and then i'm like because i
could not do that
we'll roll that tape back because you
didn't give it you were like i mean
and then and then the guy
exactly when a guy jumps out of a plane
without a parachute and lands in oh that
i don't care about no that i don't care
about and then you see you know what i
mean
that's a big deal
well because you said you could hey
don't touch you said you could do it
you said you could do it yeah i saw that
i thought that's great you said you
could do it you could do it uh i can do
i didn't say i could do that don't
[ __ ] and you said i know people can
do that
listen i said i can do i saw him go the
ramp and you know look he's fine
oh you're hating on him with tony hawk
it's your birthday i'm going to allow
this
i'm allowed to sausage this i'll allow
it
[Laughter]
look i was joking about being bored of
the kid but no you weren't you're dead
every person knows that and it's funny
you know what i mean
yeah
guys boys gets all hugged yeah
now we'll let you have salty for the day
it's your birthday we'll do whatever you
want what do you want to do i'm allowed
to not be that ecstatic about the fact
that you did the flip thing but it's
good anyways tony hawk and i like that
you didn't [ __ ] don't let him hate on
your journey experience yeah no i i'm
not hanging on that experience i love
you that's the lovely birthday you hate
me
like
obviously yeah we know he's [ __ ]
great but to see him just
like we walked in and you know he's at
the top of the ramp he's like what's up
and i'm like
yeah what's up and then he just [ __ ]
he kills it really yeah it's dude it's
insane that's what schultz said schultz
when the potty goes i don't think you
realize how famous you are he's like
yeah
he doesn't oh he does he gives he gives
[ __ ] he gives zero [ __ ] yeah about like
the he's like
yeah but you know who i was really
[ __ ] impressed with too jason ellis
remember jason's right over two in the
world
[ __ ] number two yes worldwide number
two dude he's [ __ ] serious yeah he
still gets down he's not your average
physical no he [ __ ] kills it
that's him eating [ __ ] but don't don't
go to those ones which one uh go to
maybe that one that one that one eating
[ __ ] which one this one
right there maybe go to that one is that
a video or a picture
now what's more
that's him no that's him with tony hawk
they're like doing like a
combo thing there yeah oh she's just
cool
right yeah and that ramp is not [ __ ]
little that is [ __ ] important this is
this is like tony hawk's backyard
like no it's his own facility he's got
like he says his own like yeah skate
park where he goes and shoots videos
shoots videos like a lot of people come
there to use it to like film stuff
because he's got like you know
all the stuff there he's got he's got a
street park but but the big thing there
is is his [ __ ] half pack then does he
the the bird house is his production
company that's his no that's his his
skate brand yeah
because i thought birdhouse did jackass
and stuff like that too don't they no
no no no they didn't have to do a
jackass but yeah no birdhouse is his uh
skate skate company that's pretty cool
he [ __ ] dude just seeing him like you
know there's like when you think of like
[ __ ] sports icons like he's up there
oh you know like it's just insane dude
yeah when you think you're spoiled you
okay brian you've been quiet he's bored
oh you're bored about something i was
just no i was just thinking about
something
sorry
how about what's more um impressive uh
snowboarding or uh skateboarding
snowboarding i mean they're both pretty
yeah yeah i mean like sean why don't you
john white can do both well they're
doing crazy [ __ ] those like turns and
all that stuff i mean well yeah
skateboarding the big ramp skateboarding
yeah crazy [ __ ] right yeah it's just
it's his thing right
you're strapped to a board with
snowboarding yeah like with the
skateboarding like they can like let go
pull it you know bring it back and like
all this [ __ ] like
you know yeah it's impressive both yeah
both are very impressive but like dude
to see him get down he's 53 years old
and to see him get down like he could
keep he could keep up with [ __ ]
anybody to get him on the pod so he can
still he can still get down with people
like right now the guys who are
competing he's that dude
uh for his 48th birthday he did the 900
again
if it was like he hadn't done it in 17
years or something like what's that
what's the 900 that where the twist yeah
yeah yeah for his 48th birthday he's the
first one ever to do it but first one
yeah i remember i heard him talking on a
pot he was saying how now kids they just
oh kids like kids
i know yeah that's has to bust out a
[ __ ] 900 like nothing done it's like
the night the four minute mile i thought
it was physically physiologically
impossible the first year it was done
five other people yeah once people
really said that one four minute mile
yeah i think that yeah click that video
chance which one was that that one right
there to the left of course he didn't
surf where does this one no no no no the
one uh you see the board
pink
dude i was so obsessed with
skateboarding when i was a kid did you
do it oh yeah i loved it
got into it
like that rap is not [ __ ] little like
you look down that [ __ ] this is scary
look at this dude is that him no that's
uh i think that's someone younger
but uh
wow that's him right that's yeah
that's how he's tall yeah yeah he's tall
he's three years he's he might be your
height yeah i've heard he's big yeah
yeah he's called dude
what a beast but it was cool like i got
to go back there and conquer this
[ __ ] ramp though that's like my goal
because i'm not a i'm not a ramp skater
can you do that
no i'm not
himself dude
just he just he keeps up with like
[ __ ] he i think he probably skates
that [ __ ] thing every day
but you know and him watching him and
jason ellis
get down was like
i don't know that was like a dream come
true
yeah
[ __ ] 1978.
is that what it says yeah damn
him and like uh christian were like the
biggest competitor christian is always
like the guy steve kevin
all of those dudes rodney mullen like
og's of the [ __ ] street skate roddy
mullin all right yeah
rob daredevil freestyle tony hawk rob
dierdog street guy yeah rob was a street
yeah rob's a street skater yeah yeah rob
was rob was [ __ ] beast too yeah rob
doesn't really [ __ ] with that at all
anymore
i mean it's like i don't get hurt
dude
yeah like at a certain point
you know
like i don't know i i don't go as hard
on street as i used to because it's like
i don't know it's kind of scary because
i'm like bro i'm [ __ ] damned
yeah i'm 35. mid-30s
55-35 maybe i'll get into skateboarding
tony hawk apparently made his money on
that video game because at first he was
like what is this yeah i told you that
story they talked into it yeah
yeah royalties or they want to give them
like a yeah what do you say and he was
like
i think i'll just bank on it by myself
and then
he's made all the [ __ ] i think to
this day he's still like a dope
businessman oh he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah monster monster don't
do dope dude
he was so [ __ ] nice he started
pushing me i'm like dog
yeah if you could not do that no no i
need i needed him that stuff scares me
it's because i knew like i knew how to
[ __ ] oh god he got escaped a real
skateboard oh you finally got a real
skateboard yeah you need to get them
over yeah yeah yeah we'll get down if
you if you could do one thing would it
be well if you had to choose a sport or
if you weren't a comic and you could be
really good at something what would it
be skateboarding i wanted to go pro see
for me it'd be surfing
i i'd be a nba basketball player and
make more really all you guys i know but
it's not about money
but basketball we're talking about we're
about to talk about money we're talking
about yeah about injuries done yet not
like football in basketball no there's
injuries in basketball but it's a
[ __ ]
but that training is a [ __ ] not
compared to skateboarding or football or
hockey or fighting
people yeah i've seen some people get
invested how about surfing i've seen
some people get messed up in basketball
i mean there's examples but when we talk
2013
it was louisville kevin ware
yeah yeah remember that yeah i mean
there's some shit's going to happen
there's some as far as like yeah i mean
longevity if you're a good basketball
player have you ever heard the you're
the token white boy he's 53. you heard
the injuries he had like just tell him
some of the injuries
i mean last raiders liver yeah whoo me
last trade liver broken ribs that's why
when he pulls his hands
oh it's the end you broke every finger
right every every finger
yeah and that that's football and then
yeah i'm a lucky one and you play anyway
like i don't have issues yeah you don't
have knee or back or neck issues like a
lot of guys where they're in pain 24 7
i mean i'm trying i mean basketball a
premier league soccer player would be
pretty [ __ ] dope that'd be pretty
cool do you not too now you're talking
but did those boys play you're around
it's hard work premier league then
you're on like those national teams you
live and die by your legs and [ __ ] i
mean i don't know i like it's a really
hard work [ __ ]
soccer surf sir the [ __ ] no why
sir yeah dude the big [ __ ] waves
sharks sharks oh i'm scared sharko's
there's a whale in santa barbara it's
just washed up on sure very cool just a
whale chunky chicken all good all good
chunky chunks here's the problem here's
the problem we're in santa barbara now
the whales on the beach
but see the waves hit the whale and they
pull back into the ocean that brings the
scent to
the big boys see it's not the jewel
there's a feeding frenzy we get the big
boys that come in from the deep water
i'm talking about the 21 footers
the mamas
now the drone guy is like well that's we
got 20 we don't have juveniles we got
the 21 footers and the guys are going
out there and you can see the guys
surfing
right near them
what are they saying yeah this is this
was really they should they should know
better though because you know if
there's a dead whale clearly the sharks
but the big boys like not like it's one
thing they have a 10 foot an eight foot
great white and those you get the twenty
first don't give a [ __ ] huh uh you know
what i didn't realize foot
oh yeah
look at that [ __ ] there you go
there you go and then the next day they
found a whole two more that were in
their 20s
yeah so this whale died
there's that guy well there's a 20
yeah [ __ ] now you got to go back but you
know what i didn't realize brian is that
orcas [ __ ] up sharks oh yeah i didn't
realize that they [ __ ] up great whites
oh yeah that's why they're called killer
whales oh yeah they'll rip their i
didn't realize that they'll find great
whites
[ __ ]
just their livers
they eat their liver just so they just
they hit them to eat the liver yeah i
didn't realize surgically removed oh
they're savage and then they like game
plan like don't they like launch them
there'll be a head coach and then they
there's like four of them they like
gameplay so i'm i'm in south africa i go
on a great white yeah sighting pay a lot
of money one thing and i get to know i
get to know the oceanographer and she
says well between us
you know um we're not going to see any
great whites and i go what my [ __ ]
[ __ ] will see brown bronze whalers
though we'll see other thing i go i want
great whites
that's not going to happen and nobody
knows that but i'm just telling you and
i go well thank you for confiding
poor k
okay
i'm on a [ __ ] boat yeah yeah since i
paid a lot of money and i'm rocking hard
to see a great one rock hard to see a
great way
well two orca brothers came into the bay
now that's that's cape town that would
be that would be south africa yeah yeah
the capital of great white center two of
them came into the to the bay and um
they took out four great whites four
like 20 footers they found them just
with their livers removed
every great white in the area see ya see
ya we're gonna get our things at home oh
so they know they know what's something
that i'm talking yeah they're like
oh yeah
are they the same size as great whites
or not no they're completely it's
adorable they're bigger it's adorable so
much bigger so much bigger so they're
they're
bring up this size
male orca and that's a great white yeah
great white's 2 000 pounds you know
2 500 pounds
go ahead and look what an orca is 20 000
pounds bubba 20 000 pounds
or 32 feet yeah
yeah damn only 20 feet yeah but they
they get up to uh
some crazy well they're male workers
weight 10 tons don't they like play with
their feet like launch it yeah 20 000
pounds yeah
and a great white a big great white is 2
000 pounds 20 000. so 10 times bigger
they they snack on them when they see a
great white they go yum why do they just
just do the liver
i i because the liver makes up i think
one one-third of a great white's body
okay yeah
it's a large part of the body and they
just team up on them tasty liver there's
more nutrients chappelle okay more for
the sharks yeah yeah for the orcas
that's crazy how they just team up
though yeah yeah
just like we got this [ __ ]
well there we go
there we go yeah
they're dope
have you seen it when they grab like the
scuba divers just leg and just go let's
go for a ride no
[Laughter]
my buddy joe jennifer
and he sends me video on his phone he's
on a jet ski and these great whites i
mean i'm sorry these orcas are are just
swimming right underneath them right
there it's crazy they're not gonna do
anything to you but
ah neil young's band neil young dave
spotify went with rogan over neil young
that's
crazy wait what happened you just saw
that wait what is it current event i
assume
wait what oh wow we have the current no
we have the current event of that oh not
like them choosing rogan we didn't see
that oh wait i mean i think it's
of course we knew it was gonna happen is
there a news
but it is
i don't think spotify came out said we
choose rogan over neil young no they're
just not gonna you know
wait what are you 78 this came out of
nowhere too yeah yeah it looks like that
was good
because i just saw it i saw it
sorry i thought you guys saw it i was
right there no yeah what can you feel me
yeah
do you know what happened no
god damn it so neil young uh basically
came out was like
uh it's either my uh music catalog or
joe rogan you can't have both of spotify
because rogan's uh spreading
misinformation about uh vaccines and
[ __ ]
which isn't true
none of it's true but then also
neil young yeah but from his perspective
so you know this guy he beat i think he
had polio he had two aneurysms
and he had he had some other health
conditions yeah so he's like underlying
health yeah so he's probably i i'm
pro-vaccine i'm not anti-vaccine and
rogan isn't either i think if he had
listened to rogan and rogan was asking
questions and had people in the space
who were recently they didn't want to
have the discussion well yeah most
people when they say this the
misinformation they didn't listen to the
whole thing right well no it's it's
misinformation because it's not with
what they agree with that's what so then
so you know if it doesn't align with
what they're
but he's logical rogan was asking
questions and having people who are
accredited
scientists who developed vaccines on
talking simply raising questions and
talking about conflict
it's just dialogue that's all it is but
it's also informative scientific and
these people are not mavericks they were
part of the aesthetic medical
establishment yeah they're not
anti-vaxxers did neil young really think
spotify mike okay neil brogan you're out
of here dude it would take drake kanye
west and dozier cat to all combined
together yeah it's either us or rogan
that's modified like
we ought to have a talk dude yeah and
even then i don't know if they even knew
that you don't but it would like neil
young but also there's there's contracts
in place i'm sure he's signed a contract
you can't just say like i want it off or
rogan's off if you sign a contract
you're gonna your music's gonna be on
there for a certain amount of years it's
gonna be on there regardless it was a
way of doing uh neil young he's always
had an issue with spotify because he
hates the but he allowed them to use it
though right i don't think so they
they've had disputes but how could he
let them use his music i don't know but
i don't think they've had his whole
catalog and he's like you have to make
the quality better if you're going to
have my entire catalog so i think they
were either negotiating or something
he's like you're not getting my whole
case so if it's a negotiation process
then i get it yeah so so it does it
probably has nothing to do with rogan
it's probably just no it's probably
underlying no it does but it's also like
if you're that
type of person like
brogan's your enemy like that's the flex
that's that's how you can get it
when's the last time
anybody in the last 30 years brought up
neil young
go i mean i hear about them all but but
that's my world you hear about neil
young all the time yeah people love his
music that's funny but it's like but
it's different it's different
like my world is music though i'm always
listening to music i'm always talking
music
but when's the last time you came out
with a song no brendan's saying like
when's the last time you heard him in
the news
forever not your weird music friends
yeah dude you know who's better
young larger issue is that i guarantee
for
neil
you that neil young didn't listen to
what he's most like most most likely
most people know but i think rogan
raised very important questions no we
know that but to his point like neil
young's older man like he's an older
dude underlying health conditions yeah
so from his perspective yeah i agree he
probably didn't listen to it but from
his perspective he's like holy [ __ ] man
this guy's really hurting it's what he's
hearing from people yeah yeah
he's 76 i think like eight
he's 78 yeah
yeah yeah and he's not that healthy and
obviously the cove is a big threat for
our colleagues
health conditions so it's like i get it
so from his perspective and like this is
all he can do sure okay and if you
thought somebody was spreading false
information you would i get it but yeah
but at the same time no that's i don't i
don't brilliant songwriter like
obviously a monster but also like i i
think you're under i think you're over
estimating your power i sat next to a
woman who who uh
i just wanted i wanted to see what she
was because she said she asked a fake
question the the stewardess came and she
asked a question about can i get more
ice and i said and she said i was just
hoping they would put their match i was
hoping she'd tell them to put their
masks on because the people in front of
us didn't have masks and they were
talking and i went oh you're that kind
of person so i was like okay and i
thought she was wearing two masks all
good no good we were on the same plane
i started seven minutes i started
talking to her about i just wanted to
get his perspective and and i brought up
brogan um
i just want to see what you said she
goes oh i would never listen triggered i
would never listen
i said have you listened to him no no i
would never he's just he's one of those
meatheads so there was already a
built-in prejudice yeah this idea of who
he is versus who he really is but that's
everything i know but it's that but
that's that's that's online in a
nutshell it's online like they don't
know [ __ ] right so they come up with
their own like weird hidden agenda
they're like make rogan or whoever it is
out to be a monster when they have no
clue they don't really know i've never
listened to them no clue it's
unbelievable
yeah you know and i might my issues with
a lot of people like that they're just
afraid of ideas they're so attached to
their ideas what it is it's a loser
mentality yeah it is it is yeah it's
like all right [ __ ] is man it's it's
exactly like like um anytime you have
you study one thing you have one tool in
your toolbox if you only see the world
through one lens which is racism you're
gonna see racism literally everywhere
right we talk about you look for it
you've got to have a lot of different
tools in your toolbox maybe not but i
talk about this is like one of the
things a lot of people fall into is that
if if you are if you are only a medical
professional and that's all you do you
might see the world as one big pathogen
that's like that's like fouchy like
everyone wants to hate on fouchy and you
know god bless so much that's his job
he's also damn near 80.
he's terrified yeah he's a disease
specialist so he all
all he's assumed so it'd be like it'd be
like it'd be like a homicide detective
so he's the worst yeah so his glass is
always half empty yes yeah so the word
he gets the worst of the words
you talk to a cop it's like your grandma
who went through world war ii they're
[ __ ] traumatized yes yeah and and so
all of us have to be careful not to
apply one tool to everything you have to
look at it all knowledge is about having
a lot of different tools in your toolbox
you can pull out and apply
otherwise but also have an open mind
like successful people have an open mind
yes including joe wrote like you could
change his mind
if you come with facts or yeah
something come with something it's very
rare he sticks to a point if you come
with legit that's why we always talk
about don't be married to your ideas
they're just ideas man put them out on
the table if there's a better idea let
go of that idea that's who you are you
are not your idea that an idea was put
in your head there was a time when you
didn't know
the things you know there was a time
when you didn't believe the things you
believed based on what you know somebody
put those ideas into your head yeah
don't take credit for being a good
person because you're antivirus or anti
yeah it's like it's like saying yeah
yeah it's like saying your world isn't
the world yes you know yeah
yeah it's fair yeah it's really really
important yeah
damn i didn't know that yeah what a what
a thing to say well he's an emotion neil
young's always been an emotion but but i
get it but like like you said like you
know he's
76 he's got but he's been doing this his
little career and and some of it works
and some of it he's just off on i mean
ohio is about the kent state murder yeah
yeah yeah yeah kind of that yeah he was
the guy who's like
takes a stand yep yeah keep on rocking
to the floor dead in ohio you know i
mean that was i couldn't name one song
but i know he's a b what else you got
jin
he was he wrote great songs back in the
day for sure 30 40 years ago
nothing all great musician very
influential
it doesn't mean he's right yeah doesn't
mean it's a hall of famer yeah but that
means right
all right so this is a video of joe
biden and calling on my report maybe
like a moleskine yeah it makes me like
me like more yeah because he was asked a
question about inflation
sorry 9.3 million views
[Music]
it's going to be the guy in red a red
tie behind him oh he's a fox guy
wait wait what did he say again it's the
red guy
[Music]
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid sound little [ __ ]
yeah wait he goes that's a great idea
more inflation you have a stupid son of
a [ __ ] wait wait let me see what he
says again what does he say here i
thought he just said he just asked about
more
that's what the guy in the red zone
[Music]
that's a great asset
more inflation
hey why is michael rappaport trending
you see it
where oh here under michael rappaport
hey man there's a bunch of stuff on the
screen
okay oh he filmed a shop shoplifter yeah
yep so he was in new york and somebody
was just shoplifting just straight up
and they didn't execute he's right there
by security security did
nothing
well because they defunded uh holy [ __ ]
the police
i think oh that's been really good for
your town for cities that's been a great
movie this dude
look at this [ __ ] yo that this
dude
i can't believe
i'm seeing this [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
yo
this [ __ ] guy just filled his two
bags up with everything
in rite aid right here on
80th and 1st avenue is walking down the
street like [ __ ] is gucci look at me in
my face like what's
good he's i was watching him the whole
time
my man just went christmas shopping in
january
you got the condoms
the [ __ ] the condoms
the [ __ ] like just straight up
well that's cool that he filmed them
yeah i mean it's also not cool that you
get away with that no that's that's why
it's cool that he filmed those yeah
so more people know he's great
gosh what's not to love about it i
[ __ ] love rap about what's not to
love he's so funny i love him too i saw
him like slap him man i [ __ ] love rap
before he puts his money where his mouth
is remember when i arm him yeah
i remember when you saw him i broke his
head he broke his ribs his ribs so bad
he asked for it talked about i realized
i did not ask for this he went hard i
was walking the bathroom and then
remember he started [ __ ] with me he
got a little he got a little he goes let
me put you in a staten island headlock
and then i said yeah because i don't
know
i saw your neck i saw your neck in your
head and you went like this you got a
big grin and you went like this your
hands went like this and you go because
i've never had that experience i don't
know what to do about a headlock and he
threw you in a headlock and then you you
went oh i'm going to step behind your
legs now and i'm just going to take you
out and take you down and i'm going to
squeeze you in your tongue's laughing so
that's great i love rubble it was great
one of my favorite people but he didn't
understand he didn't
i had francis and ghana on food truck
emergency food truck yesterday listen to
me right now roman is here to help you
with your ed that's erectile dysfunction
there's a lot of dudes out there man
they're suffering from that limpy it
happens to the best of them 52 percent
of guys age 40 to 70. now 55 dude 52
yeah i'm looking at three dudes in here
we bound a hundred i was going to see a
bunch of leaner issues
sometimes you get a wiener issue and
that's that's how it is nothing to be
ashamed about roman.com
fighter has got you covered they've got
u.s license healthcare professional
professional information and expertise
about erectile dysfunction you get 15
off your first month of treatment okay
prepare yourself for the moment when
it's time to go your friends at roman
got you covered man listen the whole
process it's easy shifting free with two
days shipping straightforward convenient
discreet nobody needs to know all right
to get started don't be embarrassed it's
super easy go to
getroman.com fighter today if you're
prescribed you get 15 off your first
month of ed treatment make sure you're
ready to have confidence and control
this fall roman ready
roman ready roman ready the romans are
coming yeah now i'm gonna need to fuel
up i'm gonna need focus i'm gonna need
to get good sleep i'm going to need good
digestion i need my essential nutrients
i got to do you run the thick mudder
this truck and saturday dude this
saturday's the thick mudder and i hope
you've had your on it supplements i hope
you've had your honor freaking fitness
i'm taking my shroom tech i guarantee
i'm taking my shroom technology i'm not
gonna get lighting it's too late to do
anything now i know but i know you're
gonna be sore after the thick mudder
yeah at 10 a.m and there are four spots
left to run with the thick boys at 10
a.m i'm i'm there yep go to
toughmudder.com you'll see the thick boy
10 a.m lake elsinore my whole squad's
going to be there we got special merch
just for the thick mudder but here's the
thing you got my t-shirt i got your
shirt i got a hair freak yeah you can
take alpha brain sure new mood sure
total gut of health sure [ __ ] your pants
dude spirulina chlorina doesn't matter
no after this freaking 15k you're gonna
be sore we need protein powder yeah all
right we need fish oils uh-huh we're
gonna need some some stuff to stretch
you out okay we're gonna need some
protein bars some some fat butter some
mct oil some warriors what you're saying
is an honest got me covered they're the
only it's amazing for performance and
for recovery dude they got stuff for
recovery dude if you use any other
supplement you ain't [ __ ] how about that
how many years have we been pushing on
right with you you want to look like
brian brian's 55 years old that's right
and look at me dude look at you dude i
look young i'll do i'll do a [ __ ]
splits right now i'm gonna keep myself
it's the body of a coat hanging dog
thank you buddy appreciate it go to
honor.com10 off that's on it dot com
slash fighter ten percent oh
great i love rap before it was great one
of my favorite people but he didn't
understand bro
i had francis and ghana on food truck
emergency food truck yesterday
they gave me like an eight-hour notice
so we can get a food truck so we went
and picked up chicken sandwiches i put
them in my ferrari we ate we got it out
the trunk of my ferrari it's great
dude so he's in you know he's
you look at him on on tv and he looks
like [ __ ] hercules yeah yeah in
person i mean not that much bigger than
me but like in clothes in clothes so he
but he says he goes oh you you stay in
shape you look you and i said yeah i'm
on this you know carnivore died i'm
getting ready for this thick mudder and
i go
uh what are you he's like ah 260
something right now that's cool and then
his agent goes tell him what you walk
around at before you get in camp
you ready for this what he was
oh 285. god
and i go you cut 20 pounds
almost every camp oh my god so if you
just like let yourself go you go oh two
and when i say let yourself go like just
eat whatever one goes two nights like
two ninety two abs though
oh no sir
shred it
shred it well he's just super shredded
that's [ __ ] insane is he is a [ __ ]
freak i mean that that's a guy who plays
defensive end in the nfl or whatever or
i mean yeah depend on speed explosive
speed you should yeah yeah yeah that's
exactly at the end in the nfl that's
some crazy but two n n
six five six five okay so he's six five
two that's so big now you know how our
mind's blown because he's the biggest
guy in the ufc yeah
you know in the nfl the dn's the
linebackers are look there's ten of them
on the team like that that's how nuts
the nfl is and they all run
four four four five six four now what i
what i want to do for you i don't know
if you've seen
him standing next to a guy named
shaquille o'neal oh no i know shaq's you
have no idea you have no idea how big
basketball players are until you see him
like carmelo anthony like he was a
denver guy forever grew up watching him
and then i was in l.a was at the same
restaurant he got out of the car and his
dick was all
oh my gosh
yeah well you're seven seven yeah yeah
yeah seven seven so big yeah yeah
because i don't see him out there with
other mods
and the way they move you're like oh
they're not that big dude i was like oh
my you're the biggest person i've ever
seen yeah and you're fast and light on
your feet people don't believe this is
nice when i saw magic johnson well after
he played i did a thing with him
he's 6 10 dude yeah he's also every bit
of you think i'm kidding i'm i'm telling
you he's 400 pounds of muscle uh he's
not 300 pounds he's so much bigger such
freaks he's so much bigger than that i
just kept going
you know you're so big the basketball is
a toy and shaquille o'neal's head is i
mean he's the biggest person i've seen
have you seen him pray is a little weird
it's whatever but do you know what uh
after the wait to god after the he's
great i love him after the interview i
was kind of bummed out
because i just i was asking i said if in
a perfect world i'd want you to resign
with the ufc and fight jon jones and
then they work with you to fight uh
tyson fury like they're the best
promotion in the game because i agree i
agree but you can just feel like they're
not even close man they're not
i was born i ruined my day
i don't can i bubba i don't think jon
jones wants a man that big or he does he
does that's all he wants that's all he
wants he wants really
you think jon jones is scared of francis
have you ever seen his brothers
chandler jones an all-pro all he lives
he grew up with two in ghana's he grew
up but john's [ __ ] huge too man what
did you see john a person does jon move
the same way at 260 as he did at 205.
that prime was pretty good john's a
freak don't discredit jon jones man tell
him about the greatest of all time dude
yeah he's a [ __ ] freak there is a
difference right
here now here's the thing you're
forgetting i've seen john go against
elite heavyweights i've seen what he
does don't yeah
yeah i'm telling you it's stupid to
discredit well
i would believe most experts think john
will beat this i believe that john
wrestles in ganu and beats him
that way right
i don't know i don't know
the bummer thing is is like the vibe i
got it's not going to happen
they're so far off like they're they're
just just money francis no france feels
super disrespected like you don't think
they value them and then he has this
huge opportunity to go fight tyson fury
make [ __ ] you money and that's probably
the smart thing to do
and it's just like yeah
that was bummed out
not from the interview from the vibe of
them not getting it like they're not
close to a deal right
did you get any insight on the serial
gone with was that surprising to him the
plan was always to wrestle him no plan
was not the wrestling he blew out his
mcl three weeks before ingano did yeah
oh you don't know this i didn't i won
the fight on one leg he blew his mcl out
so he's having surgery next week on his
acl complete reconstructive suit so he
didn't have uh a right knee at all so
that's you know what people were like
you didn't land a punch he couldn't
punch oh my god and so his his entire
team three four like we're not taking
his fight and then he said he talked
tomorrow usman and kamar thought because
kumar has really bad knees he can't do
like roadworks and stuff yeah and
couldn't spar like for four weeks before
certain fights like last three fights
didn't spar at all his knees are really
bad and kamara's like his brother right
and he was talking to him and he told
him how he dealt with him friends like
i'm gonna do if he can do it i can do
this goes into that fight with one leg
no training
and then he said the first two rounds he
was like [ __ ] i gotta figure it out and
then he said once he took him down
and he's like oh i i can do i can win
this way and then it's it's my favorite
moment of the fight if you watch the
corner it's uh between the fourth and
fifth round when he's going back to the
corner his coach nick sick who's like
amazing coach look sam goes we got
something now don't we and france goes
yep and he said he knew between that
fourth fifth round looking at him he was
going to win he's like he goes oh i know
that look i've been there because i know
that exact look really
yeah wow yeah wow one [ __ ] leg
so so are you going to this journey so
he has to
have video of it but it's all good so he
has to have his mcl reconstructed which
i don't even know what that is but it's
a ligament in your neon yes acl mcl pcl
but he just has mcl and acl i think they
see that
that's a nine month thing right uh six
month
six yeah
and then the mcl so both knees both
knees no just one knee he wore knee
braces on both so you couldn't tell
which one was [ __ ] up unless he was
gonna kick it
he was like why isn't francis kicking
why is he punching
he put him on one leg couldn't one leg
nuts [ __ ]
nuts different level of beast mode his
men i mean his mentality when you think
about it you know getting
[ __ ]
arrested seven times trying to get to
you know out of africa
not nuts man
nuts just want the best for him too man
and he's originally from cameroon and he
says that a lot of people from cameroon
are built like him which you know not a
lot of people that's why he told me he
was like i wish i could say i'm like
some special freak out there he goes
there's everywhere you look romero says
he's like they look like me yeah
well there's another there's that guy in
in one championship who's uh he's a
heavyweight champion yeah and uh
milan he's supposed to find out
he's a freak yeah he's insane but i
don't want like i want france to make
[ __ ] you money and have that generation
yeah that guy's kids
which he deserves yeah he's not muscular
he's from cameroon
no is he yeah originally yeah now now um
that's [ __ ] hilarious look at him
look at that
um and flexible can do the splits yes so
flexible insane one of my favorite
follows on instagram dude the beast
um yeah i hope the ufc figures it out
now now
yeah me too that's what makes me sad i
really i don't want to go anywhere else
and i i want him to fight tyson fury to
make [ __ ] you money but i want the ufc
to be involved because nobody can market
better than well now he's got to get his
knees fixed that's a long time that's
that's nine months 10 months that's a
year to fix no that's fine yeah you're
missing the point that's fine he fights
once a year anyways yeah that's all he
does so the the the
the knee surgery is
fine that doesn't hold any of this back
he that that doesn't stop negotiations
that's fine right he fights once a year
anyways
it's just them coming to deal with ufc
and the ufc realizing his value and
paying him what he's worth yeah and then
also promoting him you know he's asking
for he feels at least no he's not no
he's not not at all not even close oh
he's not no not even close that's the
problem what about paper numbers he's
not asking even close to that why not he
made 650 grand this last fight that's
it's peanuts you're heavyweight champion
not a lot not asking for 10 million at
all i'm close
i i don't know i guess there's a sweet
spot where it makes sense for the ufc
and it makes sense for him but
i mean
sweet spot what do you mean they'll find
sweet spot there's a spot where the ufc
decides i'm going to make we'll make
money and you'll make money this they
could pay him 50 million dollars a fight
and the ufc would make money yeah
so
what exactly what are your examples
it's all ego sir and here's the other
thing you got to think about
is
ufc dana white and a ton of fighters
which you want to talk about a conflict
of interest they're all owned by wme
endeavor
francis is one of the very few
superstars who was represented by caa w
m e and c a [ __ ] hater they do so
they're not playing ball with c you're
interesting because you got to get like
[ __ ] fighting promoters because you
have for the first time a guy who's
represented by your enemy and you don't
want to compromise but it's not about
your guys's egos and you're really it's
about francis but it's not to them it's
such a shock to them because all they
see is dollar dollars but my thing is
like and that's why i told france is
that if i'm in the board meeting let's
say i worked for the ufc i'm in the
marketing board meeting and we're all
businessmen our goal is to make money
and i bring up a presentation and i go
okay guys here's the thing so with
francis here's the thing
so we can be in the francis ingano
business he's the greatest heavyweight
the the most electrifying hardest
puncher we've ever had he's our current
champion
and we can work with him
and we can help promote him and give him
and pay him and then cross promote in
the biggest
fight of
[ __ ] i don't know last hundred years in
boxing for him
to fight tyson fury and i'll probably
fight two or three times in boxing
tyson fury types of rematch and i'll
probably get a wilder joshua
let's say
low estimate probably 80 million dollars
there for francis and then the ufc would
have a share in that and then also
biggest fight in heavyweight history jon
jones
so you have the jon jones fight there
you have the tyson fury type of fury
rematch and then a one-off of deonte
water
so let's go through the numbers let's
say conservally say a hundred million to
be which should be more than that but
let's just say friendly 100 million for
the ufc and francis that's possible and
you want to do what i don't 50 50 deal
yes 50 million
or
you can get your ego involved and [ __ ]
francis over make shelf him for a year
not let him fight let the first times
ever happen let the champ the current
champ walk
fight tyson fury and you know france
make you know 30 40 million dollars and
you guys have nothing to do with it and
you won't get a dime of it and you don't
see
jon jones versus francis makes no sense
drives me nuts
it drives me oh it's not ruined keeps me
up at night that's what [ __ ] up boxing
bob aaron's not talking to [ __ ] you
know uh but this is even bigger than
that those boxers make money yeah we're
talking about the br francis feels like
they devalue him they don't appreciate
him they don't pay him
he's your current champion 650 000 taxes
it's not and after paying your trainers
it's not you're not making money and
you're finding them once a year you're
gonna make a name oh and and then and
you'll love this
and then
you know he's banking on himself
remember i'm doing on one leg by the way
he's banking himself he has to beat
cyril gone
the nightmare he has to beat cyril gone
and not only does he have to do that but
he's fighting with the pressure of the
ufc he's on his last fight contract and
for negotiations he needs this fight to
go well so what's the ufc do how was
that card was it stacked no it was how
do you think it did pay-per-view-wise
terrible not terrible but but that's
maybe 300 400 000. that's why but why
would they do that but why i said that
but why because
we want to take his [ __ ] power away
from yes so they when he negotiates they
go he only did 300 000 bucks and he goes
but it was a terrible card
but we gave you the flyweights
what the [ __ ] i wait when they should
have had like the big time
i was i i said to you i go why why there
were big time fights on that card you're
not on there are they yeah now why would
you do that
now how stupid is this as a business
plan
who does that hurt obviously francis in
negotiation but also it hurts the ufc
you could have done more pay-per-view
but what's the ufc bank done they'll
move those fights down the road they're
still going to make their money off that
but it [ __ ] over france that's being so
greedy because it's also like you don't
need now remember now also remember the
guy making the decisions has half a
billion dollars in the bank
you have one sir why are you acting like
this i don't know you've won bro so why
why what i know i don't wanna get in
because they're worried that if i think
if they set this precedent president
that he can do this other guy's gonna do
it but francis is a once in a
generational [ __ ] talent
man
it's it's insane when egos get involved
you could turn him into something like
everybody would tune in he's the
scariest man on the planet everybody's
marketable as story now
oh how many movie offers do you have to
make a movie about his life oh
17 yeah one of the biggest directors the
biggest movie studios you've ever heard
of wow
oh because why he's not marketable he
speaks well knockout artist
yeah i i do think that putting him in a
ring with tyson fury this early could be
risky because he could look stupid get
knocked out no no
[ __ ] sakes don't be a manager in boxing
he'll reconstruct his knee yeah we don't
kid so him looking silly he's not gonna
look silly he'll land some punches tyson
fury
i don't give a [ __ ] how good you have to
watch your p's and cues with francis
have to hardest hitter ever you have to
he it's too hard right francis will make
40 million dollars doesn't have to do
anything ever again
right he's going to do that anyway
hopefully
well the ufc has to give them their
blessing or his contracts up well the
the ufc owns his rights to the end of uh
so january 1st 2023 but he can't do it
anyways with the surgery so he'll be
fine he'll be free but as far as like
kim looking embarrassed take all that
out you're talking about generational j
your kids kids kids yeah
well there's going to be a rematch
clause so so so um but because would you
say would you say get all the boxes hold
on would you say connor made a mistake
fighting floyd no
but forget all that anyway
and francis has a better shot to beat
fury but forget all that like you could
you still could just keep him in the ufc
and make a fortune off him and turn
turn so many fans in that direction
oh why could you give us john jones
you could do but also you so you do
tyson fury francis in either vegas or
you do it in england wherever you want
yeah and then the rematch you do in
africa so would you fight would you have
him fight tyson fury first and then jon
jones
um
i don't know that's a good question yeah
i don't know
i don't know
because if he loses to jon jones nobody
that nobody cares about him fighting
tyson fury necessarily
you know i don't i won't say that i
don't know it depends
either way they'll both go down you know
but i don't if you're the ufc i just
don't feel i i can't understand for the
life of me why they wouldn't want to
just play ball i just think he's not
asking for 10 20 30 control issue
i think it's an ego thing you know
such a shame it's stopping a precedent
from happening yeah i don't know
well you got to root for france he's
banking on himself so even ufc turns him
down you got to pray to god that fury
and him work out now fury is trump at
the bit to get that fight he is
especially after that last fight i
thought that was gonna hurt his chances
no fury's team is all in they're all in
they're all in it's out damn
it's frustrating though uh yeah it's a
shame yeah i was sad yesterday the fight
world's so crazy
talking about a guy who's learned so
crazy too his wrestling is night and day
he hasn't been wrestling that long he's
over
extreme couture though with those great
guys but you know a little knowledge
goes a long way yeah yeah i like that
you want some mind balance sarah god's
been training mma for three years yeah
for the heavyweight title three years
free free catholic freak
high-level striker though for a long
time but still at mma three years and
fight for the uc heavyweight title yeah
why is why so much money delivered in
boxing in comparison
just a while uh uh well worldwide
audience because because meanwhile
absolutely destroys them
is that fair to say yeah
dude dude if you do emma ufc paper use
compared to boxing in a calendar year
yeah they absolutely destroy him but
compared to joshua fury or something
like that that would crush
competition not to conor mcgregor fight
i don't know about that oh i do though
ufc is bigger than boxing like debate
like floyd mayweather fights
you know conor mcgregor
that's the biggest pay-per-view yeah but
but so you're saying that boxing
boxing overall does less right now yeah
right now not even close
not even close because think about name
the last box and pay-per-view go i don't
know wilder fury
did they have one wilder they have them
every month so wilder fury was that that
was pay-per-view right how'd that do not
great it didn't no
bring that up check the first one
the first one did well yeah
but let me ask you this name the last
ufc pay-per-view
every month
yeah crushing
they made the most money ever in the
history of their business last year
really
uh
name 10 boxing superstars go
well i mean you got triple g i think
you've got a trip
i'm saying
don't go old school okay name ten
current
boxing superstars
uh hundred thousand paper i'm saying
superstars that sell pay-per-views
really
well you know loma's fights were free on
espn canelo canel is your number one i'm
gonna give you all the names that'll
make money i mean like the big ones
canelo
anthony joshua
tyson fury
not dante walder anymore used to be no
never no never never never
so i i mean
keep going
maybe maybe maybe andre ward before
sort of the the guy who retired yeah
they'll get to five triple g who'd you
say
davis does all right
no he's he's getting
there i'll give him i'll give you triple
t
no no no he's not anymore nope just get
to five
um
i guess not the charlotte brothers not
even close ryan garcia
not really no well he's never had a
pay-per-view wow oh
so what what what does it say
there's different ones because they have
three fights right for yeah what was the
third we're trying to find out
nearly as much as i thought that's like
that's not that wall or furious is
between 800 and 825 that was the last
that's going to be five million if your
mcgregor fight has done more than that
yeah wow i think i think the biggest one
though pay-per-view of all time was like
uh
mayweather and pacquiao yeah i think
that's but other than that it's conor
yeah
wow god damn
well you gotta remember on average yeah
ufc pay-per-view they do that you know
you'll see
you know 270 271 273 275 every mo who
are there so with that being said like
how are the boxing payouts so [ __ ]
huge there's one guy the ufc that we
have a ton of stars this is the top guys
okay okay okay because so the ufc it's
like we have a ton of stars like the
whole main card is packed yeah we have i
can list off a ton of stars for you yeah
10 i'll rip off [ __ ] 10 superstars
for you right now everybody knows boxing
they just don't they're bad they're just
bad at marketing there are three guys
yeah they're the monsters fury joshua
canelo yeah
and by the way by the way who's the
highest paid boxer is tentative joshua
loses another one
you know yeah
they the mystique goes away who's who's
the highest paid boxer right now would
it be tyson fury tyson or or joshua
canelo yeah canelo makes me
probably canelo yeah look how many ufc's
yeah so this topology look at all the
ufc's wow
so they're consistently on top
but they're just every time yeah boom
like i said there's more stars there's
one more stars more stars yeah yeah
that's huge yeah there's more stars
then look at usman mozvidal 1.3 million
where is that at oh i see it
mazel
nate diaz you know you got izzy you got
[ __ ] monsters worldwide too whitaker
that's huge
yeah lesnar versus carl was up there
yes sir fought on that card i like to
think i added at least that ten thousand
yeah
yeah it's interesting yeah
jones yeah the ufc's they're not hitting
home runs every time unless it's connor
but they're hitting doubles every single
day every time yeah every paper boxing
once a year bubba once again and the
last big one for boxing think about it
who's canelo going to fight next
right
i mean
so the the the mayweather pacquiao is
what holds the
like the top well that's
a terrible fight
which one the mayweather factory
because
apparently mayweather's i mean
pacquiao's shoulder was [ __ ] up yeah
people people sued because they would
said well we wouldn't have bought this
for a hundred dollars if we had one arm
yeah or bet on it yeah yeah
damn that's crazy
yeah boxing has a issue
yeah
see i mean i'm close i mean besides the
heavyweights or if canelo fights bombers
heartbreaking [ __ ]
it's like it's just so disrespectful
it's like what does a man have to do you
cross the desert seven times you get to
the top of the field and you're treated
like [ __ ]
650 people think that's a lot of money
let me break it down for you man when
you when you taxes we'll just take half
of it away with taxes
what is the payout for the training
forty percent so yeah it's probably ten
percent or he pays him on a flat fee
probably not ten percent now
you know so so he's gotta pay his agent
okay but he's probably you spike
300 grand yeah i'll be making 300 yeah
you know
walk away
as a champion you're not playing first
class necessarily
[ __ ] doesn't last i mean you get a lot
of [ __ ] free if you're him maybe but he
has sponsors he does movies but yeah is
he allowed sponsors though oh yeah
not not when he's in there outside
outside the cage yeah yeah outside
though
he has a bunch of people i hope he's
making a lot of money but he could be
making oh no he should be set for like
money yes
why because he beat stephen king
velasquez jds unboxing
what else do you got to do well i'll
tell you the dope thing that you know i
do those classic fight campaigns now
the first one was you and me over my
fights we did trigger sean's fights uh
for francis we did his fights we did uh
we did rosen stroke overeem and then his
second fight with stipe and his second
fight with steve babe's talking about
how he learned so much from the first
one where he lost and he realized like
you're going to hit this guy he's not
going to go away and he goes he's the
toughest person i've ever fought because
most guys i hit they fall yeah it's him
i would hit he keeps coming
so the game plan was
it's going to take some time man
this guy's too tough damn it it was
really cool it was really cool
so cool
what's this what's stipe dude did he did
he get paid
he never really got a lot of respect did
he um not the respect he deserves time
out arguably the greatest heavyweight of
all time yeah
yeah i'm sure he's doing fine he's also
a firefighter uh this way i think
because francis is out of here no matter
if they negotiate or not i think uh
francis uh i'm sorry i think stipe and
john jones fight next i was gonna say
yeah that's the thing that's a fight i'm
very interested in yeah i don't know how
much was taken out of stipe though he
took a [ __ ] load of damage with cormier
a [ __ ] load of damage with uh in ghana
yeah so that can really really
i'd rather he retire for his own health
but i'd like to see him fight john i
would too that's a good match i would
too stylistically that's a fun fight yep
steve steve toughest happy of all time i
mean
his hat's watch his first fight
watch his first fight
got back up it's nuts
yeah francis francis speed is what's
astonishing his speed
those uppercuts that come out of nowhere
boom hit and you're like oh my god
yeah i don't know man
yeah even i mean even steve is making
more money than [ __ ] uh francis
steven making damn near a million every
time he fought [ __ ] that's such a bummer
man and they did they did they did him
so dirty with that that card
no i know
now who knows if it's intentional or not
but it lines up pretty sketchy
yeah i don't you know but it is sketchy
look at my face yeah
yeah or or it's also the ufc trying to
see how big of a draw he is on his own
you know i know it's all it's all
intentional yeah i would you know that's
you can make a star like that you can
make i know i know
i know because actually if you think
about it wasn't that there wasn't a
whole lot of advertisement for it
no and if you think about this there in
fact there was kind of none but think
about too you didn't know francis's
story like in afghan trying to escape
seven times being arrested till he went
on rogan
yes he didn't set that up that's rogan
set that up mm-hmm like you see he's not
telling his story at all i don't
understand he's astonishing because
hollywood what happened 24 7 and [ __ ]
what happened like they still do that
they don't but not it's just more about
his camp maybe it's just maybe they just
don't know how to do it they might be
the ufc don't know how to
because no but they're owned by wme they
don't know anything about storytelling
they don't have storytellers on they
don't have anybody they don't have some
of the best writers no they don't
represent anybody who's in the business
of storytelling when you're writing so
so the problem is that they're going to
have resources like there's no one
greatest writers in the world and they
wouldn't know how to take that story and
[ __ ] blow it and market it dude
hollywood's already bought his movie
right then
he's in the next uh fast and furious
he's in he has all these offers he's
good yeah just get right chris to
[ __ ] put him on his far right chris
god that was so funny
dude work with me
did you
uh do you have that send that clip to
chin clinton do you have that chip i got
a highlight tell me post that i think
chris posted you post nothing who are we
talking to oh kyle your state goes i
sent brian all the assets he just should
i stop sending no no send them to me i
gotta post but don't i've been so bad no
do it no no no dude i just you don't
post anything no i'm going to post i
love that
i think i kind of believe that's too
late
i'm going to post them i'm going to it's
too late now no i've just been i've had
a kid i've been with the baby i thought
you were bored with that baby
you haven't been there you've been on
your phone watching tick tocks right now
55. busy
time
on tick tock i'm like i feel like i'm
not
my baby
it's been a little bit consuming
and i love that i'm gonna i mean even
before that
you know what the problem is even before
the baby didn't post the baby has been
coming and i've been busy i gotta post
other stuff send me the assets christian
don't give up
no tell kyle because kyle said he's
going to stop i think i think chris i
told him
he's like it's a waste of my time i
think dalia posted that i sent him to
him and chappelle before and they just
neither posted oh [ __ ] i don't think
spells ever possible no i post i post i
post i post that's ugly i say they never
send me anything i post
i gotta post i thought you're ugly
i actually was i was in the process of
posting i got distracted
you said christmas arms how much did you
post chris posted it
the
uh it's all right chris right there
no it's not the far right one
i thought that's what you were talking
about no it's the sizzle i said i just
dropped it to chin i saw a sugar sean
you sent him the fight companion bit god
damn it's all good it's all good
yeah that's
so funny live on there we'll just play
this right now so many people text me
about far right chris
it was so [ __ ] funny my
i'm sorry just i go don't do it
ready
this is how
stupid with me
rabies he's gone like this nope shut up
who cares about anything let's get rid
of rumble
he's good he's so good
he actually makes that sound really good
a good
[Laughter]
i'll rip that vaccine right out of my
shoulder
spread
election problem
joe biden is a lizard
chris come back to us man
let's go shoot up comet pizza
hey crap back come over to the center
you got right chris
he's drooling
right chris has rabies
it's not over
she's not locked up
[Laughter]
no
hey
oh
why do i look like i'm on a soft lens
and in black and white
man it's great you're right i'm glad i'm
back man you take that go brandon cheers
coffee bean and tea leaf work with chris
work with me man you don't want to nudge
me on over to this
it's just because they have some puddles
that's [ __ ]
that to me is so funny he's crucified
personally i know me he makes me laugh
so [ __ ] hard man what he is
the best of all time oh he's so silly
god is funny he's so right chris
work with me work with me work with me
just because they have some he had a
mask i guess he had a shirt like this
and they go you need a mask over your
ear she's like what are my ears out
there i'm wearing a mask over my ear
he's like
work
i'm a sense
you're nudging me over to the right hey
chris goes because i have to watch that
part back over because the finest part
is he goes i know where you live and you
here you go come on over man
[Laughter]
are you come on over come on
come on
did you see his post about his kid
his his kid yeah see the post he did
about his kid holy [ __ ] i think that's
it that top one
this one here yeah it uh
pretty powerful [ __ ] seven minutes long
you want to put a little bit of it i
watched it [ __ ] it wouldn't it be what
you guys want but it's pretty [ __ ]
powerful all right see it you guys saw
me one yeah i was i didn't watch this
last week and in the middle how's it
real quick for me before you play this
so after all the [ __ ] chris has been
through and let's say you want to hate
on crystalia
you're gonna tell me this cancel culture
you're gonna tell me he's not a better
person he is a better person you're
gonna tell me that he hasn't learned
from whatever mistakes he may have made
you're telling me after all the therapy
he's been through having a kid after you
watch this this isn't a better human
being
play it dude
before you play the one one of the
things i noticed
is the when i saw him when he asked me
to do ochsner with him it was it was the
most simple it's the most simple thing
but it was such a big thing
as soon as he got there he came up and
he just hugged me yep and i was like
i was like you never like i didn't say
it but it's like he's never done that
but he he hugs me he's just like like a
like a hug of like real hug yeah
and i was like
well not that i didn't accept like the
way he would greet me before you know
but like i've just never seen he went in
a bat he went in a boy and it came out a
man yeah and it's like don't that's what
you want yeah from a person like
the the growth and like you want to see
the island for good we are we are works
in progress all of us
all of us
she was bringing calvin to a movie and
that i should come and i ended the
podcast and i had to get to the improv
and i couldn't make it i'm like babe i
don't want to do that and i'm upset
because i want to be there for calvin's
first movie and she was like well i'm
with him out and i never really get time
to like kind of like
de-stress and unwind so i'm just going
to go see the movie and i was like i
would really appreciate it if you don't
you could do anything else i want to be
there for my son's first movie and she
was like well we're already inside
anyway
i was like okay you know i don't want to
make a thing out of it
but i was upset
swallowed it and i um
and then i and then i i had to get ready
for the show and then i went to the to
the
uh get my coffee as i do i do my thing i
[ __ ] get in and i do my uh
i i do my routine you know i went to the
coffee bean i got the coffee actually i
think i went to the [ __ ] starbucks
even but i went to starbucks and i went
to the improv and when i went to the
improv i was you know i kind of was
thinking about my son watching a movie i
was like i hope he has a good time but i
was still kind of bummed out and i got
into the green room at the improv and i
hear tata and calvin's there
and i just everything just melts away
i'm not bummed out anymore i'm not upset
and kristen's a hero
and he's just that data
and he runs to me gives me a big hug and
calvin's in there and i almost start
crying and i i put it on my other
youtube channel uh more chris
uh more crystallia and it's uh on the
it's the pre-show with chris it's called
and um
my face even the side of my face you can
see like how emotional dude i [ __ ]
everything else felt fell away and it
was the first now instead of seeing my
son's first movie it was my first first
time my son was going to see me on stage
and i was gonna be hanging out with him
in the green room with my other people
who still you know look it's been a
[ __ ]
weird two years for me to say the least
and the other comedians on the show that
were still [ __ ] rocking with me and
that that uh in the face of fear still
support me um
is just was such a beautiful thing man
and that
you know to think that my career used to
be the most important thing and now it's
not my family is the most important
thing and now i'm at this show and my
family's there in with two of now the
most important things
it was just too much for me to even
handle dude it was just so emotionally
uh amazing and i was nervous for like
the first time
in a long time besides the first time i
came i came back i started doing
stand-up i was a little nervous but dude
to have i was like calvin's not even two
and i'm nervous for this person to watch
me because i want him to [ __ ] like me
i want him to like me and it wasn't like
i want him to think i'm funny like he
doesn't even know what the [ __ ] i'm
saying
as a matter of fact i went on stage and
he was just like that that that guy he
was so confused and chris was like she
watched me for 30 seconds then he was
like trying to run around and she was
like be quiet be quiet and then just put
on something on the phone for him to
watch i'm like why should i pay tickets
for this [ __ ] i told him she should just
put my specials on that would have been
funny because no matter what if it's on
that phone he'll just zero in on it but
it was such a beautiful thing man you
can go watch that video on on the more
crystallia channel uh
the uh pre-show with chris
it gets pretty deep on this yeah it was
just [ __ ] really wild and i love it
and i just loved that moment man and i
loved that moment
it's just so much it's so much feeling
you know
it's crazy to be a person
a period
actually
it's so much
if you let it be you know what i'm
talking about
like that's why i say life rips it's
like it it it's so
it's it really is a feeling of
what you let it be
right like i could have the old me would
have walked into that green room no i
didn't have a son right the old me the
the unaware
sleepwalking through life guy
didn't have us it wasn't when i had a
son but the old me would wouldn't have
necessarily stopped and thought about
that and taken that in i wouldn't have
allowed it because it was too much
feeling
right i talk about how i don't like
music a lot because it's artificially
making me feel these emotions and that's
what life was to me it was you're not
going to make me feel that way i choose
how i feel
but if you're doing that then how much
of the life are you living
right like nobody wants to be around all
day and cry at every [ __ ] waking
moment there's a lot of sadness in the
world but there's also a lot of
happiness and you need to feel all of
that to be a person if you're not then
you might as well be in the metaverse
and have a jerky [ __ ] foxhead
right true
you might as well because you're not
really living our boy grew up life is as
much feeling as you let it be and as
much as you let it take in because man
having my son there in that green room
having my son there knowing that he was
watching his dad
do his job
for him too you know
like
i actually do it
it was the reason why i went back on
stage
it's because of him
i didn't
you know i checked out i was in a bad
[ __ ] place man i did not want to you
know there were
weeks and months at a time where i
didn't i was like [ __ ] it dude
so many people threw me on the under the
bus [ __ ] them i'm not doing stand up
anymore that's not a community i'm not
in that community i don't want to be in
that community [ __ ] that i don't want to
be in that community
you know
the world has a certain p a opinion of
of of me or whoever the [ __ ] has an
opinion of me or whoever the [ __ ] it is
uh
you don't know who i am
and
there was a long time where i just
wanted to give up and
the only thing
that made me
get back on stage at certain points was
my son's going to be 20 one day or 15
whatever the [ __ ] it is of a mind to ask
me
oh hey dad you used to be a comedian
and i would have to say yeah and he
would say
well why don't
you do that anymore
and i'd
i'd have to say a version of
i let the world get the best of me
or
i let people say and believe that i'm
something that i'm not
and i gave up
and when it comes to my son
that's just not an option
um
so yeah
so that's what
that's what that means to me having him
there
and that's what that means to me having
him there with all the people
that i love
and still love
whether that be
you know
[Music]
brendan schaab
theo
craig conan
chappelle lacy eric griffin you know and
i'm just naming some of them but
you know and my fiance and calvin who uh
who knows me
grew up you know i'm so glad you had me
listening to that the [ __ ] i've known
him i've known him since 2006 2007 2008
and to watch him
like really change i don't see
instagrams i
i didn't know i didn't either like right
before he walked in here it's crazy to
[ __ ] i don't see yeah i'll see you
i'm glad i posted i get out that's
probably anything
i wrote him i wrote him after i saw him
on stage at oxnard and i i kind of
you know i said my thing to him you know
because i'm just so proud of him i'm so
[ __ ] proud of him yeah that's cool
what what do you hear him talk about
feelings yeah it's just it's
growth management a lot of work but it's
a boy this is dope a lot of work yeah
still doing it it's yeah still doing it
doesn't matter it's dope to [ __ ] i'll
text him and i'll make fun cause he
touched back like dude i was in [ __ ]
therapy like for how many hours
how many hours are you doing this
you ain't buds [ __ ] therapy right now
i woke up in the middle of the night
thinking about my birthday and
you know one of the interesting things
is i kind of decided
sometimes you make a decision and a
decision takes a couple seconds and what
if you did the exact same speech yeah i
know right
i'm just regurgitating what he said
[ __ ] so embarrassing but i think that
um
you can make a choice man when when when
life does something to you you can
[ __ ] decide i'm i'm pissed and i'm
gonna be bitter and i'm gonna be a you
know i'm going to be this any other
thing or you can just decide that this
is going to make me the best version of
myself ever and what i decided in the
middle of the night last night and i'm
old to the game here but um
i was just like i'm going to
i just kind of saw the best version of
myself
i really did and i'm doing a lot of [ __ ]
that i didn't think was possible i
haven't told anybody about but a lot of
stuff that's going on now for my for me
was just because i went through some
stuff and i and i opened up my options
and it's starting to come together and
um
you know you can decide that i don't
care what happens to you you can you can
imagine the best version of yourself
that you never thought was possible and
you could do that and just reach for
that yeah you can let it [ __ ] keep
you
where you
where you
feel yeah because a lot of times man you
don't want to do anything but mold you
don't want to do anything it can destroy
your spirit and if you let it it wins
well i mean just watching it i mean i
spent so much time [ __ ] i mean i've
been journaling since [ __ ]
you know day one
and you know i met chris in 2011
and then you know seeing where he's at
now it's like
you know and coming from that world of
just constantly doing that [ __ ]
you know looking within you know
yourself
like he is really
[ __ ] doing it different like
it's a
different [ __ ]
smart human being
wasn't an accident back then and now
that he's become
disciplined no i don't think anybody
would say chris isn't talented he's also
disciplined actually he's also oh my god
he does he wrote that's the thing like
before covered he did more sets than any
comic you know every single night
there's oc it's ocd but it's his work
ethic yeah nuts yeah he's not more sets
than anybody you know yeah any comments
never lately whoever's your favorite
comic has not done more sets than
christopher correct guarantee it now
he's saying something now he went back
to the drawing board and he was like i
was doing silly stuff because that's all
because i could get away with it oh yeah
watch him
now he's out saying [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
crazy cool it's dope it's it's it's like
i'm really happy to see stuff like that
because you know especially when you
know i'm gonna have to edit that where
he says bren schaub eric griffin spell i
see brian callan we need to get that
who can do a crystalline impression
i've only known you longer than he said
he said there were some others he didn't
name everybody yeah yeah they're others
in the vlog that he was referencing for
that when you're emotional like that
sometimes you forget [ __ ] yeah obviously
but you name the most important
yeah
but also by the way how about people
like that who make it out about them he
didn't mention me like hey texas hey
dude you saw the video dude are you
kidding me after all you are
friendly
hey mr sensativo you get the [ __ ] out of
here
that is the worst that's cool video
though yeah
it was a little long but i figured i'm
just going to show you guys
i'm so glad you made me watch that that
that was great but the connection my
gift i made my day today that was my
gift
i made your day
got me a little emotional yeah not
really boy grew up
and i'm glad that i right now i'm glad i
opened this podcast with me talking
about how my baby's boring and then
so we got that right guys i really think
that like me and chris has never been
closer and it's really good kids it's
that it's that [ __ ] it's that daddy [ __ ]
yes like you just you're playing the
same game now when you're a dad and like
the schedule
i was telling him he was like what do
you do for touring i'm like well before
i had kids we even when tiger was first
born i was on tour so much but i'm
different because i had to at the time i
had to get those reps in but now it's
like
i do a tour date begin the month end of
the month that's it my biggest three
my biggest regret is i you know i was
never i was i was touring i was just
never around yeah with my kids and you
know why this year around you know why
because i was raised that way and and i
didn't think that's what you know i
didn't realize i didn't think my kids
needed me you know what else i think
[ __ ] them i didn't think my kids even
no they were too young to understand or
notice so for me
i didn't know that i wasn't raised this
is a thing and i i mean my my dad was a
beast so it's i learned it obviously
from my dad and love i got from him but
from you know there's a ton of parenting
books out and it's science the
relationship you have with your kid the
bond you build you have to they're five
if you miss those critical years when
they're five it you're you can have a
relationship but it will never be if you
don't make that connection yeah before
they're five you're in trouble man yeah
i have a great connection i mean i i was
there i'm not saying but but i'm saying
but you don't you learn as a dad you
know where you hunker down is when your
kid's sick
that's go time you should look at that
like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah because when your
kid's sick when they're like two or
three when they're like super sick and
you're there it creates this [ __ ]
bond where they go oh dad gots me yeah
that's my ride or die and the bond is
nuts house dude yep so when they get
sick or they need you to get hurt and
you're there all the time like me and
tiger best [ __ ] the one thing that's
when he gets sick he doesn't go i want
my mom yeah because where's my dad the
one thing that saved me was i lived at
home right so i was i wasn't divorced
until much longer much later
but when then part of what happens is
when you move out thank god i get along
with their their mother very very well
when you move out you get this frantic
terror that you're not going to be able
to parent them because you're not
they're say so it made them change it
made me more present but you need to do
what garth brooks did
you listen to this baller [ __ ] move
chris gaines aka garth brooks did yeah
divorced his wife
bought the house next door there you go
when the kid the kids i mean obviously
they know they're divorced but before
the kids wake up he rushes over makes
some breakfast get some clothes get them
ready for school when they come home
from school rushes back over he's in the
house makes them dinner puts them to bed
they fall asleep goes back to the crib
gangster death yeah how dope is that
yeah yep because he he has the income to
do it i never thought i could try my
kids as much as i do now like that the
amount of time i spend with them is just
that's my favorite thing
let's miss the show tonight and stay
home with your kid that's my gift to you
nope i'm not going to do that no no we
just haven't talked now no i know you're
now hold on who's how to talk about
appreciate you you have one zero to five
let's not [ __ ] this up
i know number five right this is avatar
you're the blue guy the horse we want
this but hold on right now you're this
okay but hold on you're this
like that i know and he's not opening
his eyes it's not the funnest i'm not
staying home for that
i got a show
i'll be i'll hang out after this i'm
going home to see him i'm gonna [ __ ]
hang with him i'm feeding him what the
[ __ ] he's being he's breastfeeding but
i'm but i'll put him on the tent
i'll put him on the tip i bet your
girl's tits are popping right now
hey hey
no no no no i get all the [ __ ] that you
said comment on the men's girls titties
and [ __ ] that's how we talked
they're behind but still
yeah that's aggressive you're taking a
suckle
all right that's it
catch brian
no man i got i got the baby's well fed
he's feeding
hey man you're looking painful and don't
do that you know you gave me a couple
pinky pokes it's weird when you're
hating on chappelle for the the
skateboard i had to do that to you a
little bit huh
okay i'll let you have it it's your day
it's your birthday yeah well kids all
right that's it kids hey next week uh
chappelle lacy myself
uh
we are gonna be doing the dirty bird in
atlanta georgia that is next thursday
friday saturday atlanta georgia we're
gonna learn it and do it on the stage
david lucas too right david lucas yep
the whole crew will be out there atlanta
georgia we got new tour merch as well uh
you can only get in person that's
atlanta george georgia february 3rd
through the 5th then sacramento
california is february 24th through the
26th ooh job just added a new date
nashville tennessee zany's one of my
favorite spots march 10th through the
12th daddy's coming here you go baby
yeah
uh daddy's gonna be i think at the
american comedy club uh february 17th
two shows get your tickets february 17th
american comedy club that's the only
date i have in [ __ ] february besides
february 19th with sam tripoli uh our
conspiracy social club you can get on
rockfin or every monday anywhere you get
podcasts we are doing at diversion
amusements get a better name diversion
amusements uh uh in vegas february 19th
to two shows uh las vegas nevada
boom and february 25th and 26th i'll be
in kansas city kansas city missouri at
the comedy club of kansas city march
10th through the 12th i'll be in
springfield uh missouri i'm just gonna
get your boy huh okay
okay why i'll be here i'm ditching him
bryan's baby oh just announced if you
refresh chin yeah uh just got announced
i'll be in salt lake city uh april 9
april 8th and april 9th at uh wiseguys
comedy club that's a big deal yeah big
deal your first headline wise guys yeah
dude he's got wise guys yeah like you
don't like city you're gonna [ __ ]
love it yeah no we've been there
sorry
happy birthday happy birthday see you
guys see you guys tonight